alors vous étiez dans la première vidéo
dans l'église vous regrettez totalement
honnêtement depuis que j'ai tourné cette
vidéo avec benjamin ma vie c'est un
calvaire
faut savoir d'abord que géreront
recontextualiser la chose puisque
benjamin est venu ici pour s'exprimer
plusieurs fois
et clairement ça me surprend de voir la
version change à chaque fois donc je
mets aussi ici pour m'exprimer là où la
version 12 septembre vient justement je
vais y venir donc benjamin c'est savoir
que tout le monde me dit que c'est
l'amie de benjamin ce n'est pas de toi
l'ami de base c'est une connaissance de
soirée que j'ai connu il ya deux mois
environ c'est très récent et donc un
jour on a décidé de visiter paris de se
promener parce que moi j'ai un peu tout
un pari j'ai vécu ici mais voilà et on
décide de reprendre cette église parce
que tout d'abord moi j'aime bien ma
visite est donc ma chair mon petit tour
je m'assois et puis après est venue
l'idée du tic toc
donc faut savoir que le tictoc j'ai bien
fait attention à ce qu'ils soient
tournées dans le respect dans le sort
dans le sens où il y avait pas le son
j'ai bien écrit qui n'est pas le son qui
est personnes dans l'église et ça a duré
deux minutes par la suite semblé sortie
et ça s'est terminé donc le lendemain
donc la soirée passée moi j'essaie de
pas calculer mon téléphone parce que moi
quand je passe sur les réseaux jeu suite
au coeur celle du maquillage je fais un
peu de dollar beaucoup d'armes m et le
soir même je décide de ne pas regarder
mon téléphone et le lendemain je me
réveille et là je me dis mais c'est quoi
ce
ce qu'est ce que j'ai fait plein mais
merde j'ai merdé et là je suis en fait
là j'ai blessé des millions personnes et
c'est pas c'est pas dans mes valeurs
c'est pas moi quand j'ai vu ça j'ai
directement réagi je me dis bon ok je me
calme je décide de supprimer directement
les vidéos sur instagram et monty knox
et
donc de m'excuser en biographie
instagram est historique parce que
vraiment je n'avais pas la force et le
courage de m'exprimer à une caméra et
appareil vous l'avez au téléphone
bernard vous l'avez pas dit
alors justement le lendemain du coup
quand je réalise la gravité des choses
je décide de lui envoie un sms un
message au jeu de contact et donc je moi
je pars du principe qu'on a fait des
conneries à deux on est ensemble on est
deux personnes avaient la vidéo il ya
des conséquences graves dont maintenant
je lui demande s'il va bien première
chose à faire déjà deuxièmement je lui
demande s'il pouvait supprimer la vidéo
parce que ça rien d'insister tout est là
après tout ça je vois qu'il ya plus de
réponses donc là je me dis qu'est-ce qui
se passe ensuite je vois qu'il ya
plusieurs apparitions détonante et pmp
pour moi ça m'a choqué et donc moi quand
ils vous répondez par message ou quoi
vous parlez moi vaut savoir que pendant
dix jours tu as tout ce qu'il a fait
après cette vidéo qu'il a fait après il
ne m'a jamais répondu il m'a jamais
contacté il m'a jamais parlé donc moi
j'étais seul dans mon clairement chez
moi en train de paniquer à la tour des
minimes h salle de moi une mauvaise
image alors c'est parce que je pense que
je veux refléter sur les socios mois sur
les réseaux pour pour montrer les
talents artistiques je suis je suis dans
le maquillage mais vous regrettez parce
que derrière votre vie a été un enfer on
vous regrettiez parce que vous avez
blesser les gens je regrette parce que
surtout parce que j'ai blessé des gens
d'accord clairement quand je vois tous
ces gens tous les goûts tous les
commentaires ou quand j'ai réfléchi vous
également essayé de lui dire à benjamin
on va faire une connerie tu vas pas
continuer à faire des conneries parce
que sa vidéo l'a22 ce week-end là elle
est vraiment inadmissible pour moi c'est
celle là pour moi c'est la plus grave
qui ait fait
vraiment c'est là c'est encore là il a
encore passé un cap oui mais il nous
fait presque de la peine 20 bus quand
ils n'arrêtaient pas de se vanter mais
dans le mauvais sens suite à l'arrêté
pas de se vanter de passer dans
l'émission il disait d'ailleurs sur son
compte que la france entière parler de
lui et l'a en fait il se rend compte que
plus personne n'a envie que ça y est
c'est passé ils postent des vidéos
toujours pire il a lancé il a fait une
première vidéo ici il s'est moqué c'est
honteux de jean pierre pernaut un jour
après sa disparition 0 reprises il a
fait sa vidéo avec la kippa 0 reprises
et il en fait il était dans cette espèce
d'escaladé de la provocation jusqu'à
arriver sur sur cette vidéo avec le
coran et plus personne n'en parle et
quelque part je suis content parce que
ça montre aux jeunes que la provocation
gratuite et le buzz gratuit ça ne dure
qu'un temps et qu'il faut avoir un
minimum de talent pour durer donc sens
assez bien alors qu une paulien il
voulait se désolidariser ce soir 2
voilà de ce que fait jean jamin gérald
mais tu as raison guillaume sauf que
benjamin en fait il est accro et le buzz
c'est une drogue dure et en fait il est
addict alors il a fait un buzz il a été
invité il a fait un deuxième buzz il a
été invité et là il se dit mais pourquoi
ça marche plus en fait pourquoi ce buzz
là qui est quand même beaucoup plus
trash encore plus provocant away est
encore plus dégueulasse pourquoi ça
marche pas en fait effectivement moi
comme comme raymond j'ai peur c'est à
dire que quand on est accro mais en fait
on a une overdose une overdose c'est un
accident donc je sais pas de l'accident
de double à venir et forcément ça va mal
se terminer pour lui parce qu'il doit
être totalement désemparé de voir que ça
ne marche plus et que la machine à buzz
ne marche que qui n'est plus invitée sur
les plateaux télé voilà est clairement
aujourd'hui je demande si tout ça ça pas
été préméditée par lui de son côté ce
n'est pas une stratégie je ne sais pas
parce qu'avant je ne sais pas se faire
dans ta tête c'est pas quelqu'un qui m'a
l'air sain mais quand j'ai vu que
c'était vraiment une mauvaise
fréquentation dans le sens où
tu m'as trahi dans le sens il n'ya pas à
trahir comme ça du jour au lendemain
comme là on sent prêt des vidéos wii il
a insulté crash les religions sépare
donc c'est pas mon idée c'est pas mal
c'est parce que je pense maciocia cette
image là à m'ajouter à l'idée votre
notoriété parce que vous étiez beaucoup
plus philippe j'ai aussi bien oui voilà
au départ mais exactement y avait des
millions dont je me posais la question
savoir si c'était pas à manigancer plus
le début voilà alors il ya un truc qui
tourne je vous dis voilà queen paul
c'est que il ya bien eu pas mal de gens
qui disent que c'était vous le meneur à
la base c'est vous qui avez une idée de
tout être qui est dans une église par
que vous l'aviez proposé à une autre
influence euse qui était venu nous voir
rubini kara qui est venu nous voir
dernièrement qu'elle avait refusé un tel
marché et qu'est ce qu'ils ont ils vont
nous dit qu'on allait vos parents quand
ils ont vu cette vidéo mais par en bas
comme toute personne sera dé la vidéo
ont été surpris et choqué
et j'ai quand même eu la chance d'avoir
des parents là pour moi et qui m'ont
soutenu comme d'ailleurs beaucoup d'amis
pendant un long moment savoir que j'ai
été j'ai coupé tous mes réseaux tous mes
contacts parce que j'ai vraiment besoin
de voir rien de rien voir quand je vais
tous les jours sur twitter toutes les
applications mattel mat et de benjamin
partout j'en pouvais plus mais après la
vidéo vous avez tous ses fichiers
majorelle soir non le sar dont tu vas
chez benjamin on était avait fait des
vidéos après on n'a pas fait on était
dehors dehors et après moi je rentrais
chez moi à s'asseoir ensemble j'étais
d'accord fait passer jeudi après on
était dehors et après moi je rentre chez
moi je me suis couché était fatigué et
l'augmenter passer ça et depuis plus de
nouvelles de lui
mmc sms
par rapport aux essais parce que j'avais
envoyé par rapport à l'esprit mais la
vidéo et il m'avait clairement dit que
pour lui c'est normal
qu'il savait ce qu'il faisait donc voila
et parasites une nouvelle mathieu vous
comprenez qu'on invite plus benjamin va
évidemment mais mais surtout parce que
au milieu de tout ça évidemment je suis
très choqué par ce qu'il a fait mais je
suis inquiet pour lui aujourd'hui
vraiment vraiment vraiment parce que je
pense que ça va mal se terminer et
j'espère vraiment pas que ça va se
terminer parce qu'il a 18 ans que c'est
un gamin mais là la vidéo victimes on
sait bien que la montre pas j'ai été
extrêmement choqué et là il va dans un
niveau de violences et d'insultés qui
fait que même pour lui à moins de sortir
même dans les visages étaient
inadmissibles et je sais que la demande
m la protection politique policière pour
le moment de ce que j'enseigne la pas et
je pense que voilà vraiment il faut
retirer la vidéo oui à ce que je
comprends pas c'est vraiment ce que font
les réseaux sociaux vous désirez vous
excusez moi ma que jamais c'est à tenir
et twitter pour une fois sur le cias est
normal
dans mes jambes
tout bas je vois ils ont eu son twitter
un style or ils ont viré yeux ça
non mais bon bah il a été viré pour
beaucoup de monde ça sur lui la reine de
la provocation la provocation la
provocation et lui et continue dans mes
ailes dès qu'on dit bouba l'énergie
parce qu'il a un bilan il a critiqué son
mec mais c'est pas grave gilles alors si
pour tout à fait d'accord avec vous sur
le fait que les raisons
nota l'hypocrisie complètement les
réseaux sans doute gens qui font sans
doute parce qu'il se sent il est que cet
hymne cessé d'appeler vous en parlerez
mais pour moi il anticon avant tout
merci coût de 66 ans pas du tout il est
pas pro poutine a bâti une bonne a
jamais dit qu'ils étaient pro poutine
bantry ciré anti donneurs de leçons à
non gérald landes
outre evans n'est pas n'est pas pro
poutine et pro anti donneur de leçons
c'est pour ça qu'ils vous aiment pas
trop souffert merci ok je viens pas bah
voilà alors oui non alors il ya une
hypocrisie totale des réseaux sociaux
sans doute parce qu'ils estiment que ce
ne sont pas des attaques politiques et
de la provocation ça passe mais c'est
injustifiable en revanche moi j'ai une
voix un peu discordante concernant
benjamin j'aimerais bien qu'il soit là
pour en parler encore avec lui
on les donne une troisième sur freenode
franchement là la vraie juillet lalande
a tout essayé comme dirait mon avis nous
rions la troisième il ya une escalade il
dépasse ses propres limites mais moi je
prends ça trois fois pour des appels et
j'ai pas envie de laisser un jeune homme
perdu comme ça finisse en réponse à ces
mêmes faisait trois fois des yankee oui
vous pouvez pas venir parce qu'il rend
dans ta jeune homme en détresse lors des
appels j'ai toujours envie de l'écouter
et d'essayer de l'aider en file indienne
année vous occupez d'association avec de
brahim personnes à problème je suis
désolé parce que là on lui a donné
énormément de chance moi ce que j'aurais
mais c'est la première fois qu'il est à
peu près le discours de clinton donc
c'est ce qu'on attendait
mais voilà les français d'ailleurs
qu'ils venaient pour faire des excuses
là c'est une escalade et autant te dis
que c'est une drogue dure c'est vrai
page et de prendre de réels risques
puisqu'il reçoit des menaces de mort et
il continue donc c'est hallucinant c'est
fini il ne faut plus il ne faut plus
l'écouter il n'a rien à dire qu'est-ce
qui nous a dit qu est ce qui ressort de
ce qui nous a dit il a monté en la
première fois ci il a aucun argument il
se perd enfin non vraiment moi je
réussis m'étonne c'est que tous les
médias chance me la leggia ont pris ça
directement pour leur cible ce sujet là
et ont clairement faire un truc
politique alors qu à tout travail et
aucune attention politique il y avait
vraiment aucune intention de toucher des
communautés de moi j'ai pas compris
assez non mais c'était grossier quand
même quand on est une fellation dans l
église j'ai validé à toute politique et
de monter tout ça sur la politique la
stratégie commandé vingt ans après en
barrant mon prof des élections ça
arrangeait pas vrai ça m'a choqué mais
pas du tout c'est lui qui va nous dire
que c'est un message l'homophobie
mais bon c'est ce qui me dérangeait
politique aucun aucun parti n'a rien
repris insurgés arrivent les plaindre y
arriver par l'équipe derrière exemple on
a dit on parlait du blasphème est drôle
un système alors moi lors les maritimes
existe mais je suis contre tout ça et tu
me fais 7 contre le contrat le blasphème
je suis pas contre mais je suis content
utilisation pour blesser les gens tu
veux dire que tu as été instrumentalisée
ta vidéo était instrumentalisée à des
fins politiques c'est à dire car à miser
pour visionner par rapport au blasphème
est ce qu'on avait la voix la droite ou
alors aux bas salaires aucune attention
ça n'est quand même pas tous en même
temps dit que ça allait choquer
nom m'a choqué pas forcément mais
non franchement j'étais inconscient ce
jour-là est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui je
tenais vraiment devant tout le monde
devant la caméra et c'est un plaisir de
faire aujourd'hui si demander le pardon
parce que ça c'est important et puis
moi clairement eu
vraiment je suis je suis je me reconnais
pas quand j'ai dans mon geste que j'ai
fait l'année dernière et moi j'ai pas un
projet je compte aller de l'avant
faut savoir que c'est quelque chose que
qui m'a touché beaucoup ça va pendant
longtemps j'ai j'osais pas sortir de
chez moi j'avais tellement de l que je
ne sais pas en fait dans un miroir bon
je me bats pour la victime non plus mais
aujourd'hui on doit être plus on ne
parle plus non ça je vais attention à la
roue et après je traîne pas trop dans
les endroits fréquentés et c'est à tout
ça j'ai eu la chance quand même d'être
bien accompagné et par exemple mme
nabila mounib invité sur son plateau
pour m'exprimer
il n'a pas jugé il ya pas que je voulais
bien non je n'ai pas brisé je traîne pas
d'un endroit de quoi fréquentés du monde
l'attention parce que voilà quand elles
mêmes je m'arrête bonus et mp moi je
fais je tue c'est un bad buzz tu viens
pas le lendemain surenchérir moi je fais
une connerie j'ai pas je me cache cette
fois c'était une connerie je me tais
j'aimerais aller marcher sauter pmp le
lendemain comme un cirque pour sauf ce
soir je mens pas
mal de voir que les moyens d'action
tourner et pas à bras rugby erc et avec
elle et c'est si vous voulez vous pouvez
l'appeler
1,66 et raymond cassan
et je l'appelle reggae vous connaissez
benjamin un peu mieux que nous quand
même selon vous c'est quoi son but et
jusqu
alors comme je disais je te connais oui
et non un peu mieux que je fréquente et
bien sûr
clairement c'est quelqu'un qui vit qui
disent allez tous à paris et
je pense que clairement il est perdu je
sais pas ce qu'il veut donner comme
image en tout cas moi ça me début on m'a
déjà cette vidéo qui est actuellement
honnêtement ça qu'est ce qui chez sa
maman au rendez vous et ce qu'ils
cherchent je pense c'est que il a besoin
d'attention c'est quelqu'un d'attachant
et quand je vois tous ces personnes qui
réagissent tout le temps par rapport aux
benjamins ces vidéos qui fait tous les
jours jeudi battant il ya encore des
gens qui râlent ça tous les jours cette
forêt agir c'est choquant mais c'est son
jeu en fait s'il a compris le terrain
qui faisait j'aime bien son comportement
parce qu'il vient il se désole tu te dis
c'est fini avec lui à les jeux tu viens
tu demande pardon et tu verras quand tu
dois machin faut pas trop je trouve un
peu dur avec lui c'est vachement bien ce
que tu as fait la passe qu'il faut pas
rester à côté d'un mec comme ça parce
que ce mec là il va il va mettre sa vie
en danger faut pas traîner avec un mec
comme ça parce que là il en train de se
mettre en danger pour moi sinon avril
est très malade il se met en danger
après tu es venu ce soir on parle de lui
et là où je rejoins gilles ce qu on dit
faut pas l'inviter faut il aura dû
l'inviter zilina on aurait dû l'inviter
sylla viens pour son droit de réponse
c'est très bien maintenant je ne veux
plus qu'on parle de lui et moi je veux
faire comme talent toi je veux qu'on l'a
on l'enlève des réseaux sociaux ah oui
mais là on attend ce soir de plus à
l'avenir est devant ce soir de lui il
faut l'enlever des rénovations voilà lui
il a fait la caution pour sa part admis
après il ya des gens qui disent je vous
dis moi voilà sur les réseaux qui dit eh
ben il montre qu'on a le droit au
blasphème par l'ars et vidéos ah oui
c'est vrai oui si on ne peut pas on peut
pas aller mais le supprimer on va pas
lui supprimer ses comptes sur les
réseaux parce qu'ici on a le droit au
blasphème et que ce qui fait c'est du
drop la traîne si on lui supprime ces
vidéos mais il a il ya des gens énorme
non il ya beaucoup de gens blessés il a
déjà ils avaient cessé les religions
ribes le sénateur webb est pas allé dans
l'île oui oui mais apparemment on peut
faire ce qu'on fait alors demain demain
demain demain je vais plus jouer au plus
loin moi j'aime bien aller plus loin pas
des jours l'arrivée demain dans la rue
oui malheureusement tristement on va lui
mettre un coup de couteau où on a
découpé l'ardèche 6 et 4 on a peur on va
sortir on va marcher maintenant sortir
avec des drapeaux et on va marcher on va
dire le pauvre benjamin
dans une friteuse
gérard lamarche elle aimerait maintenant
bien même touche à travers toute la
merde tu veux chercher là mais bassam a
vendu que tu peut convoquer tu peux
chercher la merde en provocant mais là
c'est ce qui fait la paix entre les
dirigeants mais bien
je te met des claques dans ta tête tu
sais pas c'est comme ça ce que se dit et
charlie hebdo c'est un journal satirique
tu viens l'acheter tu viens dans le dos
de kiosque pour l'acheter c'est des gens
qui travaillent charlie hebdo le droit
au blasphème je suis pour le droit au
blasphème je te dis pas le contraire
mais tu sais bien fait moi ça les
regarde comment tu d'efforts mes propos
je te dis juste que s'il arrivera même
je compris nuitées par six pour ses
parents mais moi je me dirai à
genoux face à ces
contraintes qu'on subit déjà démarché
rien c'est une marche une enfant j'ai
récemment chez les messieurs légitime
n'aurait pas que tu aimais pour aller
marcher dire je ferais pas ça il a des
blessures il a placé tous les jeunes
cerveaux confondent les en fait de la
sem et profanation c'est à dire que
humble du blasphème comme l'a fait
charlie hebdo on est tous derrière quand
il leur arrive quelque chose elle ça ne
nous battons seraient tous derrière
quelqu'un qui auraient profané une tombe
ça arrive souvent en été mais je suis
désolé là on est dans un pour moi
qui profanent est revenu à la raison
douchka raison daniel tout cela autour
de la pas bien toi qui profanent une
tombe qui s'amuse c'est philippe
osset si on posait la question la foulée
des troubles s'est excusé moi quand des
réseaux sociaux d'arrêter les réseaux
sociaux il ya plein de gens qui disent
on ne peut pas le stopper des réseaux
sociaux puisque place afin qu'il ne
connaît pas de débit c'est ça le
problème un âge il mais oui en fait il a
chaque fois même dans son dans son
délire il est extrêmement mal hein si je
puis dire c'est clair qu'il nous
repassent pas le cadre légal et c'est la
seule barrière aimerait tant qu'ils
s'attaquent en tant que ça c'est moi
quelle race est malin j'appelle meinau
mais la finition de chic mais laisse ma
fille parce qu'ils s'attaquent pas aux
individus aux gens mais aux religions il
est dans le cadre de la légalité et
c'est une tradition français de la
liberté totale d'expression fille
choquée mais moi je suis extrêmement
choqué des vidéos mais l'opinion
individuel que l'on a ne doit pas
interférer le cadre légal il ya des 1%
qui n'est pas y adhérer c'est moi en
disant j'ai peur pour lui j'ai peur et
oui à santé ça me fait de la peine pour
ses parents j'ai peur pour lui j'ai
commencé comme ça en disant ça oui mais
c'est le mec on vient ici ils font
fahren il dit qu'il va attaquer le camp
ensuite il dit qu'il va attaquer deux
synagogues ensuite il dit qu'il va
attaquer n'existe une église de choses
les réseaux sociaux pour protéger comme
a dit cyril ou vous laisser laissez le
faire laissez le faire et quand vous
allez avoir après dans le journal où nos
informations il s'est passé un truc fed
alors c'est dramatique
18,1 pour lui dire informatique 18 ans à
18 ans il monte des sociétés à 18 ans et
son soutien et manille à 18 ans la tête
elle est là
l'air avec à 18 ans et était père d'un
enfant toi mais tu peux déconnecter un
enfant attend un enfant à lui représenté
non ça dépend de plein de choses de ce
mécanisme
c'est bon on doit passer en dessous
dessus j'ai fait tenir et simplement
dire que moi je pourrais être votre père
même votre grand-père un poème à rien
je vais gamme de la bienveillance pour
vous parce que vous êtes jeune mais
faites attention parce que le monde est
violent et vous avait choqué les gens
mais c'est stop arrêtez
d'accuser j'ai vraiment grandi et
maintenant quand je passerai un tick
tock de pêcheurs au moins dix fois et
façon c'est simple moi j'ai appelé jean
barrull moi je me suis excusé
aujourd'hui dans une suite vidéo
d'excusés sur youtube moi si demain il
ya encore un truc à me reprocher ça
existera passagers directement approché
après ça ne se reproduira plus c'est
très bien mais je vois aller de l'avant
et paul wilson très bien quinn paul ah
oui mais on peut vous appeler paul
cargnello base est pas surprenant queen
[Rires]